All right,
everybody,
let's start in.
So the midterms are graded for those of
you that are not doing the paper and uh,
you'll receive them back
on Thursday in class.
Uh,
and uh,
people for the most part did quite well.
So it's a good news.
Today I want to talk about tobacco and
the legal paradigm that surrounds tobacco
because it really provides a,
I think,
an interesting comparison
to some of the other,
uh,
legal regimes that we've taken a look at,
so far in the course,
including those that surround
air quality pesticides,
atomic weapons testing,
hazardous sites,
and plastics.
So how has tobacco,
uh,
managed and what's its history?
And I've come to think about this,
this a history really is a conflict of
perceptions of rights and obligations,
uh,
particularly,
the right to,
uh,
to,
participate in markets.
Uh,
the right to,
uh,
speak freely,
the right to advertise a as opposed to
the right to be free from exposure to
chemicals that are recognized
to be quite hazardous.
So all of these cases that we've
looked at so far during the term,
I really have had a raise questions about
a risk and a different approaches to
managing risk.
What are the different legal strategies
that you might think about to,
uh,
to take on a hazards such as this?
Well,
one is taxes.
Uh,
we'll take a look at tax policy and,
and to how tax policy creates
a dependency relationship,
uh,
between an industry and governments,
particularly,
particularly at times like
this of a budgetary stress.
We'll take a look also at
a place based restrictions,
uh,
so preventing the sale of,
of certain hazardous commodities in
certain kinds of environments so that,
uh,
no,
we can no longer purchase tobacco products
and vending machines in the United
States.
Instead,
they have to be purchased
a over the counter,
uh,
by someone who would check identification,
a sales restrictions of different sorts,
uh,
advertising restrictions,
a fair warning requirements on,
on tobacco products.
Uh,
also compensation.
how are we going to manage compensation
for those that claim that they've been
harmed by the products?
How are we going to
subsidize the industry?
Uh,
you probably know that,
uh,
many different commodities,
agricultural commodities
received a rather high subsidies.
So,
uh,
what,
what has been the,
uh,
the relative history of
tobacco subsidies compared to,
to other commodities?
Uh,
how about,
uh,
regulating the chemical
content of tobacco,
uh,
flavoring agents,
coloring agents,
uh,
the shape of tobacco?
How about a tobacco products designed,
uh,
to,
soothe?
Or how about the regulation
of nicotine itself?
Uh,
known to be,
how about the ban on all tobacco products?
Uh,
has anybody thought about
doing that at any scale?
Uh,
well,
many governments have,
have chosen to ban use of tobacco,
tobacco products inside buildings.
So public buildings commonly,
uh,
now restrict the use of tobacco products.
Uh,
also how about socializing the industry?
An idea that a Kessler came up with a,
at the end of his book.
So what's the scale of this
issue in terms of economics?
Uh,
about $50 billion today
in consumer spending,
while in about 15 million people in the
United States smoke approximately 600
billion billion cigarettes each year.
Uh,
the overwhelming majority of those,
uh,
cigarettes by the way,
are,
are a lit and smoked indoors
so that this is very much a,
an indoor air quality issue,
uh,
about 4 billion cigars or smoked also for
40 million pounds of tobacco or burned
indoors every year.
How about tobacco related illnesses?
He's very little debate
about this compared to the
other types of problems that
we've looked at that are
managed by environmental law,
including pesticides,
including air pollutants and drinking
water contaminants managed by the safe
drinking water act or chemicals that are
migrating from hazardous waste sites or
the quality of the scientific evidence
about the effect of tobacco and human
health is really the gold standard.
It's similar in quality to,
uh,
our understanding of the role that
radiation plays in inducing cancer.
Uh,
there are also about
470,000 different suppliers,
wholesalers and retailers that are
highly dependent upon this industry.
So this is a recipe for
a enormous conflict,
uh,
in Washington about how to
use the different strategies
that I just went over.
All,
Huh.
So the way that the laws have
evolved in the U s was laid out,
I think fairly well and Kessler's book.
Uh,
but the,
the,
uh,
strategies that the
government has relied on,
now I have included hazard warnings,
predominantly a control
over advertising claims and,
uh,
the use of specific media outlets,
age restrictions.
So that a,
within United States right now,
the,
uh,
use of tobacco products,
the sale of tobacco products is restricted
to those that are 18 years and older.
Although there are some
states in some counties that,
uh,
now demand that you
need to be 19 years old,
for example,
in Nassau County and
Suffolk County in New York,
a demand that you'd be 19 years old.
Well,
if you look around the world too,
there's quite a bit of
variability in some of the,
the,
uh,
poor nations of the world.
All you need to be 10 years old.
I in France,
you need to be 16 years old.
Uh,
in Japan you need to be 20 years old.
So the idea of age based a restriction is,
is really quite variable across
different jurisdictional boundaries.
Uh,
restricting access,
uh,
making certain that a,
you can't just walk up to
a machine and put your,
your,
uh,
now seven or $8 into it to,
to get your,
your pack of cigarettes out,
the removal of subsidies,
uh,
but not prohibition.
So the Congress considered
a variety of strategies,
but they always backed off of prohibition.
How about industry strategies to
maintain their share of the marketplace?
What have they done?
Well,
one of the first things that
they did was to focus the issue.
Could focus government's
attention on labeling.
And as with the pesticide labeling and
labeling of pharmaceuticals and food
products,
uh,
labeling is a,
is a problematic form of
conveying a sense of risk.
Uh,
this is especially different,
uh,
than,
than pesticides or,
or,
uh,
some drugs,
in that,
uh,
the,
the product itself is addictive.
It's addictive.
Uh,
predominantly because of,
of the nicotine content,
uh,
they industry also fought,
to confuse the evidentiary
base on health effects.
So just like a nuclear weapons and just
like pesticides and pharmaceuticals.
Uh,
the knowledge about the danger grew
from the industry research itself.
So the American Tobacco Ends Institute,
uh,
for example,
might be thought of similarly to the
atomic energy commission or to the
pesticide companies that conducted
their own analyses of data so that they
became the source of data to
demonstrate the absence of,
have a clear understanding about,
uh,
adverse health effects.
Also in advertising.
You know,
they,
they really took a very bold moves and
I'll go through a variety of different
advertising strategies today with you,
uh,
to,
associate tobacco use
with the ideas of freedom,
uh,
values of nature.
Uh,
also sociability and sexuality.
So the imagery is very important.
It's extremely important
and also quite persuasive,
uh,
to the very young,
they focused on the costs of regulations,
uh,
not the costs of health care.
And it's quite interesting to think about,
uh,
the sea change that
occurred as a result of,
of litigation in Florida against tobacco
companies that resulted in a settlement
so that,
uh,
many attorneys general in the
United States banded together.
Uh,
and,
uh,
we're able to reach a settlement for
approximately $250 billion to be paid out
by the tobacco companies to
different states here by year.
A study at Yale,
uh,
just a couple of years ago demonstrated
by the way that the money that came into
Connecticut did not go
into educational funds,
uh,
that,
educational programs to
prevent tobacco use or to,
to,
uh,
increase the,
the,
the rate of,
of,
uh,
quitting of tobacco use,
instead it was diverted into a
variety of other state needs.
So the,
uh,
this balancing of,
of costs of regulation,
uh,
as opposed to the benefits of the
product has been central in their,
in their logic.
Also,
the idea of preemption,
uh,
just as pesticides are preempted
a so that they can't be,
they can't be regulated differently.
The labeling can't vary
from state to state.
Uh,
so that,
uh,
the tobacco companies went to the federal
government and were successful and I'm
preempting state and local regulation,
uh,
regarding both labeling
and tort litigation.
So preemption basically prevents this
patchwork quilt of regulations from,
from,
uh,
being imposed on the industry.
If you look at the variability
of taxation by state,
it's also quite,
uh,
quite curious.
So that in the state of Rhode Island,
uh,
the,
tax state tax is about
$2 and 46 cents per pack.
Uh,
whereas the state of Kentucky,
you was down to 3 cents per packer
and this is several years ago.
So states have the authority to
set taxes at different levels,
uh,
to give you a sense of the magnitude
of importance to a state's budget.
Uh,
the,
uh,
sales tax represents if a California
increase the sales tax by only 50 cents a,
it would raise nearly a half a billion
dollars per year if New York or increase
their taxes by about 50 cents a,
they would increase their income,
their revenue by about a
third of $1 billion per year.
So that states have become quite highly
reliant upon the sales taxes as a,
uh,
important for hormone of income.
How about,
uh,
some of the statistics about
smoking prevalence in education.
So,
as I said at the beginning of the lecture,
about 50 million people out of a little,
over a few,
over a 300 million people
in the United States smoke.
Uh,
but what about,
uh,
their level of education?
And what you see is that,
that,
uh,
current smokers,
the,
uh,
tend to decline as a percentage,
with education less than high school.
Uh,
you see here,
uh,
the current smoker smoking rate
is much higher than it is a,
for those that have university education,
so that those who understand the health
effects are less likely to adopt,
uh,
tobacco use and they're more
likely to consider quitting.
So to give you a sense,
also,
the magnitude of,
of tax revenue across
some of the larger states.
Uh,
the,
the u s income is now over a
well over $10 billion per year,
uh,
that,
states enjoy.
Uh,
tobacco also has been a
target for a subsidy removal.
So compared to corn as an example,
uh,
corn and joys about a one and a half,
$1 billion,
uh,
subsidy or did and 19 and 2004,
or as tobacco subsidies are,
uh,
less than a billion dollars.
Today,
advertising is a very important component
of the cigarette companies budgets,
uh,
so that they are spending today close
to 20 a $22 billion on advertising and
promotional expenses.
Uh,
and this amount of,
to about $53 for every
person in the United States.
Uh,
this is a 22% increase
over over previous years.
So what you find is as,
as the market goes down,
as he adoption rate among the young
go down or they will vary there,
they're targeting,
uh,
of,
of advertising,
uh,
by,
by gender,
by a ethnic group,
uh,
as well as by age.
So that expenditures for advertising
have increased in response to increasing
regulation in these declining,
uh,
adoption rates.
Targeting children
through advertising is a,
a,
an important thing to consider.
And,
and,
uh,
kind of curiously,
children played an important
role in and the evolution of,
uh,
prohibited policy with
respect to nuclear weapons.
Uh,
they played an important
role in the control of led.
They played a really important role in
the adoption of the tougher a particulate
matter standards,
uh,
for pesticide,
restrictions.
So that Ms. Case,
a recognition that children
are especially susceptible to,
to,
uh,
persuasion by advertising,
has similarly led to two recent,
uh,
more restrictive legislation.
So Joe Camel provides a,
a,
a pretty interesting example.
This a series ran between a 1988 and
1997 and about 3000 new smokers less than
18 years.
Uh,
we're,
we're picked up,
uh,
per day and about a third of these people,
if they persist in their habit,
I will die of tobacco related illness.
The,
uh,
appeals,
are,
are well known to everybody.
Uh,
here you see Joe Camel,
uh,
with a,
a woman,
a cracked of woman in the background.
Uh,
the images a tough,
uh,
the image a is one of a fighter pilot.
Uh,
and there he is smoking his cigarette.
The idea of this series was,
was modeled after a television
show called Miami Vice,
uh,
really modeled after James
Bond and Don Johnson,
uh,
in one study showed that
nearly a third of all,
all three year olds a match the
character to the cigarette brand.
And amongst six year Joe camel was
his fee as a familiar as Mickey mouse.
So,
uh,
within a matter of three years,
Joe increased camels market
share from one to 33%.
And in a less than 18 year old range,
a sales increased during that three
year period by $500 million per year.
And this is believe now to be one of the
most successful advertising campaigns
in history.
I think about,
uh,
the,
the imagery as well.
So,
uh,
here on the left hand slide you see a
woman having a presumably just reached a
mountain peak and,
uh,
then reached into your
pocket for a lucky strike.
Uh,
the Marlboro man,
also the image of masculinity,
a horse having just roped the steer,
uh,
and also,
a key symbol for the corporation.
Looking back in history,
you can see also the appeal to women,
particularly as a weight control strategy.
So to keep a slender figure,
no one can die,
can deny.
It's a why as to reach for a lucky,
uh,
and also the appeal to,
keeping mom on a,
on a steady course.
So,
uh,
here you have a child in the add,
before you scold me,
mom,
maybe you better light up
a Marlboro a and g Mama.
You sure enjoy your Marlboro.
So things are,
things seem happier in the family.
So somebody is cranky,
uh,
associate,
the use of tobacco,
uh,
with a mood swing,
a physicians were enlisted to
support advertising as well.
Uh,
so here you see some ads
from the 1930s and 1940s.
Uh,
it's,
it's actually interesting
that you can go back through,
uh,
the,
these old volumes of life magazine or
a national geographic or time magazine
over in,
in Sterling Library.
And take a look at the patterns
in advertising over time.
So a 20,000,
679 physicians say luckies
are less irritating.
It's toasted.
More doctors smoke camels
than any other cigarette.
Dennis to also were part
of the advertising game.
And anybody that,
uh,
has smoked or no smokers know that
cigarettes generally steam teeth,
especially those without filters.
So the idea that putting a filter on the
end of the tobacco could remove the a,
the dangerous product.
It could remove the,
uh,
the,
the discoloring agents in the,
in the compound.
Uh,
uh,
that's an interesting idea.
Santa Claus even got into
the act for awhile while,
so a guard against throat scratch.
Uh,
there's also a long history about a
reliance on gender and women have been
extensively targeted.
A women,
I tend to have lower
adoption rates than men.
Men do a buy four or 5%
in the United States.
Uh,
and the,
uh,
the dominant marketing
strategy has been one to,
uh,
on themes of both social desirability,
and independence.
Uh,
and these are normally conveyed by thin,
attractive and athletic,
uh,
models.
Uh,
this history goes back quite a ways and
you see it in different parts of the
world as well.
Uh,
so that,
uh,
the highest estimates for cigarette
smoking among women tend to be in,
in the,
uh,
southern and tobacco growing states,
such as Kentucky,
uh,
where it's about 28.1%,
whereas nationally only
18% of women a smell.
Also,
you can,
uh,
recognize certain patterns of reliance
of different brands on different types of
imagery.
So whereas Marlboro concentrated on,
uh,
kind of a machismo image of masculinity,
I,
Virginia slims instead concentrated
their efforts on women,
always slim women,
uh,
always tough women.
Uh,
you know,
uh,
yeah,
I got a tattoo and no,
you can't see it.
So the image of sexuality
and also strength not
dominated their imagery on the
tobacco companies also tried to
influence cultural acceptance of tobacco
products by encouraging
actors to smoke on stage,
encouraging producers,
uh,
providing subsidies.
So that tobacco use was noted.
And about 75% of all movies that
will reviewed several years ago,
in 43% of the movies showed scenes in
which tobacco use could be interpreted as
attractive a with qualities
described by teenagers as sexy,
exciting,
powerful,
cool,
sophisticated,
rebellious,
and celebrity.
Celebratory.
And 25% of the movies included some
of the anti tobacco statements.
Uh,
top build actors lit up in
59% of all movies reviewed
another,
uh,
example of Virginia Slims Advertising,
riding a motorcycle,
uh,
the idea that you would,
take on risks,
uh,
not only writing them,
so motorcycle,
uh,
but also riding without a helmet.
So that,
uh,
the,
the idea that,
that,
uh,
you're tough,
you're,
you're attractive,
you're slim.
Uh,
these are all images that,
uh,
are very strategically
designed to encourage adoption
rates in different parts
of the world.
You find a different ethnic groups being
targeted using a variety of different
strategies.
So a Virginia slims also tried to create
the idea that that independence and
cultural pride are linked to tobacco use.
Uh,
so that,
uh,
there's a terrific amount of variability.
Also the promotion of
different kinds of events.
Uh,
when I was a kid and
we'd go to rock concerts,
uh,
people would commonly be there with,
these big trays,
a haul over their shoulders,
uh,
with sample size tobacco packages,
four or five,
uh,
cigarettes and a carton.
And they were given out
freely and some bars,
the promotional activities,
uh,
also,
freely distributed tobacco products.
In this case,
you,
you a,
you probably recognize that or knew that,
uh,
different kinds of races and athletic
events were sponsored by different groups.
Virginia slims,
for example,
was,
was quite active in
promoting tennis tournaments.
Uh,
the,
the Virginia Slims and invitation
was an example of that.
A NASCAR racing was,
uh,
promoted by a lucky strike,
the moral borrow 500,
uh,
as another stock car race.
My Dad,
when he was in World War II,
uh,
he would,
he will,
uh,
after he came back,
he always told stories about his,
uh,
k ration kit so that they
were given a k rations,
which often included spam.
Uh,
but,
uh,
also peanuts and,
and,
uh,
chocolate bars.
And he would tell about always having
the cigarette pack a freely available to
all of the Gis.
What a brilliant advertising technique.
Uh,
recognizing the addictive
power of tobacco,
how few cigarettes it really takes to,
to,
uh,
cause a physical addiction,
and putting them into every k ration,
uh,
virtually ensuring that you
would have a high addiction rate,
uh,
for among the Gis.
Uh,
once the millions of soldiers
came back to the u s today,
if you look on the Internet,
you'll find a variety of
different advertising schemes
in different parts of the
world.
Uh,
Rjr stir the census campaign is,
is a good example.
And some of them include a
product auctions and encourage
you to become a member
so that they can advertise and provide
you with the information about different
kinds of,
of,
of discounts on products as well
as to promote their products.
Now,
different countries to have taken
different approaches to labeling.
And,
uh,
you know,
that I'm not a great fan of labeling as
a way of conveying knowledge about risk.
And I don't think that it really,
uh,
often helps a consumer to understand the,
the true benefits as opposed to the,
uh,
the adverse effects
associated with products.
But the Canadians have taken a tougher
stance than we have in the United States.
No.
In the US,
you know that we have these little
boxes on the sides of the packets or
sometimes on the backs of the packets.
Uh,
that may say,
warning,
this product is known to cause cancer
where this product is dangerous to your
health or this product to it causes
emphysema or exacerbates asthma.
So that,
uh,
there are a variety of different signal
phrases that are required to be cycled
through on the sides of tobacco products.
Uh,
Canada has a system where that whereby
they demand that the front of the
package,
uh,
include photographs of,
of a health loss.
So here's an example of what a heart
looks like after it's had an attack.
Uh,
the darker area,
for example,
in,
in this photo,
uh,
another,
example cigarettes cause lung cancer.
So someone on a heart lung
machine on lying in a hospital,
uh,
cigarettes hurt babies.
Uh,
so that doesn't appeal to
a protection of the unborn,
uh,
and,
of children getting people to think more
carefully about what they're doing to
their young.
And something that might wake up,
uh,
teenagers,
tobacco use to can make you input.
It can make you impotent.
Uh,
that's news to many people.
there are also prevalence
rates that varied by ethnicity.
Uh,
so that American Indians
and Alaska natives,
for example,
uh,
have,
adoption and prevalence
rates are far higher than,
than we haven't in
other ethnic minorities.
Uh,
and also,
uh,
Asians have one of the lowest adoption
and addiction rates in the nation.
Most smokers begin his teens.
And,
uh,
this is,
quite interesting to me.
Uh,
when I saw this,
a David Kessler showed this slide to me,
I'm going to show a series
of slides that he provided a,
uh,
when he used to lecture in this course.
And you see that,
uh,
the adoption rates begin
at a very young age,
uh,
so that the up to 12 13% occur,
beneath the age of 12,
uh,
beneath the age of 15.
You see,
you know,
roughly a 25,
50,
maybe about 50%,
uh,
of the age of,
adoption.
So that uh,
the target,
uh,
of,
of a youth has become a very important
aspect of advertising campaigns among the
tobacco companies.
In fact,
a RJ Reynolds in 1984,
uh,
stated,
that young smokers had been the critical
factor in the growth and decline of
every major brand and company
over the last 50 years.
So if you can addict a single
individual who is 50 years old,
uh,
you will have a much lower rate of return
than you would if you could addict to
a 15 year old.
Another a comment by on
Rj Reynolds executive.
Realistically,
if our company is to survive
and prosper over the long term,
we must get our share of the youth market
and speaking again,
the executives says evidence
is now available to indicate
that 14 to 18 year old
group a is an increasing segment
of the smoking population.
Rj Rm as soon establishes a
successful new brand in this market.
If our position in the industry has
to be maintained over the long run,
if we were to attract a
nonsmoker or pre smoker,
there is nothing in this type of product
that he would currently understand or
desire.
Instead,
we somehow must convince him with wholly
irrational reasons that he should try
smoking.
Very interesting idea.
So here you have a product,
uh,
that,
you know,
would be a disgusting to too many
people that had never tried it.
I remember when I smoked
my first cigarette,
I just coughed and spluttered my eyes
watered a hated the taste and I hated the
smell that I carried around.
And,
and,
uh,
so that,
this is,
well,
this was,
were recognized by the industry that they
needed to create a other factors that
would encourage people to,
to adopt the,
how about the,
uh,
the legal framework that,
that,
uh,
this sits within?
Well,
the surgeon general's report that
was released in 1964 was the first,
uh,
thorough and,
and,
uh,
comprehensive indictment of the effect
of tobacco products on human health,
uh,
concluding that,
it did,
uh,
induce lung disease.
So the Federal Trade Commission,
uh,
at that time began to regulate advertising
and it concluded that a cigarette ad
advertising was deceptive,
uh,
that advertisers had a responsibility
to warn the public about the health
hazards of smoking and that
the Federal Trade Commission,
uh,
then proposed labeling the amount of
tar and nicotine and include a statement
such as caution,
cigarette smoking is dangerous to health.
It may cause death from
cancer or other diseases.
The idea of preemption,
uh,
originated with respect to
tobacco products back in 1965.
Uh,
and,
uh,
it prohibited the Federal Trade Commission
and states and local governments from
acquiring any other label on cigarette
packages in any warnings to cigarette
advertising at least until 1969.
There's also the federal communications
commission that plays an important role
here,
uh,
particularly the fairness doctrine.
Uh,
so by 1967 more money
was spent on television,
uh,
tobacco advertising than
for any other product.
Uh,
and in 1966,
a citizen John Vans Hoff wrote to CBS
TV in New York and requested that some
other responsible spokesperson
be given a chance,
uh,
to present contrasting views.
On the issue of the benefits
and advisability of smoking.
And the FCC responded and
required a significant amount
of time to rebut tobacco
advertising.
Uh,
concluding that we hold to the
fairness doctrine is applicable to such
advertisement.
The fairness doctrine has its origin
in 1949 in a rule that required
broadcasters to devote some
of their airtime to discussing
controversial matters
of public interest,
uh,
and to air contrasting views
regarding those matters.
In 1969,
the public health cigarette smoking act
was adopted and it demanded a cautionary
label oh,
with a key change in the phrase,
uh,
so that the surgeon general has determined
that cigarette smoking is dangerous
to your health,
not may be dangerous to your health.
It also required a blackout,
a cigarette commercials.
Uh,
as of January in 1971 on television and
radio stations estimated a loss of about
$220 million in revenue.
So we're a recall that I argued that,
uh,
this,
this industry,
uh,
creates a very large
revenue base for states.
Uh,
it also created a terrific revenue
base in terms of advertising for the
communications industry.
What this means is that the
industry support was quite
varied and quite wide and
diverse.
Uh,
that,
uh,
the tobacco industry,
was,
had the capacity to go to Congress and,
uh,
find allies that would not
be immediately intuitive.
So about seven and a half percent
of their total advertising revenue,
uh,
had been associated with the
tobacco industry at the time.
So,
uh,
warnings,
advertising and age restrictions,
uh,
between 1965 and 2008 became the key
targets of Congress when they enacted six
different statutes that they
required that all packaging,
uh,
have labels on it.
They required that,
uh,
the advertisement of tobacco products
through an electronic communication medium
would be prohibited by the
Federal Communications Commission.
We're,
we're also required a,
these statutes require the secretary
of Health and human services to report
every three years to Congress on research
findings concerning tobaccos addictive
property.
Uh,
kind of curiously,
you know,
to combat the,
the origin of the scientific studies,
uh,
occurring predominantly
within the industry.
The National Institute of Health
started funding independent studies.
Uh,
so that,
uh,
just as,
as you find in the
pharmaceutical industry or in,
uh,
the,
pesticide industry,
uh,
the,
the conduct of independent science
really became quite important to,
to,
uh,
the government's capacity to,
to a amount of challenge,
to be evidence that was
presented by the industry itself.
Also,
these statutes,
uh,
made states the receipt of certain
federal block grants contingent upon their
prohibiting tobacco product manufacturers,
uh,
a manufacturer or retailer or
distributor from selling these products,
uh,
that included not just tobacco,
not just a cigarettes,
but also cigars and,
and,
uh,
chewing tobacco to individuals
under the age of 18.
So what are the,
uh,
estimated health effects from tobacco,
irritation as well recognized
lower respiratory infections,
uh,
are recognized.
We're recognized early
reduced lung function,
increased risk,
uh,
for asthma,
an exacerbation of
asthma among those that,
uh,
had it previously.
Uh,
non respiratory cancers,
early onset of menopause,
uh,
also environmental tobacco smoke,
can cause brain tumors
and cervical cancer.
That's environmental tobacco smoke.
That's not a smoke that's inhaled by the,
by,
uh,
the,
the smoker.
There are really three different
kinds of smoke a cigarette,
uh,
would,
would produce,
one is a smoke that's inhaled through
the tobacco itself as it burns.
The other would be what's
called sidestream smoke.
That is given off by the
burning tip a of the product.
And the third would be the smoke.
That's exhale.
So each is a different
complex of compounds,
uh,
between three and 4,000
different chemicals.
Uh,
so it's really been a,
a very difficult task.
Understanding which of these chemicals
is responsible for which of these health
effects.
Uh,
but this is,
it's a,
an interesting problem.
It's similar in respect
to diesel emissions,
which is also a complex mixed here.
Uh,
so that the effect of the mixed year,
uh,
has been the subject of study,
as opposed to the analysis of
individual components in the,
uh,
in the mixture.
So exposure during pregnancy,
a harms of fetus,
uh,
and synergistic effects exist with radon.
Uh,
the natural gas that's given
off by a granitic rock,
uh,
that we have here in Connecticut.
Uh,
and,
uh,
the combination is known
to cause lung cancer.
Uh,
environmental tobacco smoke has
increasingly become a target of,
uh,
regulation and,
and,
uh,
its relationship to heart disease,
is well supported by about
13 epidemiological studies.
Uh,
now 14.
environmental tobacco smoke is
responsible for other kinds of effects,
uh,
that include heart disease,
impairment of platelet function,
damage to the inside lining of arteries,
uh,
interference with oxygen
delivery and used by cells.
And it can also depress
cellular respiration and
enhance fatty deposits on a
vessel walls that can,
uh,
exacerbate cardiovascular
and neurological illnesses.
In 1997,
a Harvard Study of 32,000 nurses was
released and found that the relative risk
of coronary heart disease,
uh,
among those that smoke
compared to those that did not,
uh,
it was about two.
So the two fold increase of risk of
heart disease among those that smoke,
uh,
and they attributed a 60,000 additional
deaths each year in the United States,
uh,
to environmental tobacco smoke.
So that,
uh,
it wasn't until the 19,
late 1990s at these estimates,
uh,
of health loss associated
not from smoking,
uh,
but being in an environment
where other smoked,
uh,
became quite sophisticated.
20 fold increase in
death from lung cancer,
uh,
was attributed to environmental
tobacco smoke has stated,
uh,
or,
in EPA in 1992 passive smoking report,
uh,
William Riley was the administrator of
the Environmental Protection Agency at
that point in time.
Uh,
and,
uh,
he also was a Yale
graduate and a returns to,
you know,
quite often.
And I spoke to him about his effort
inside the environmental protection agency
in the early 1990s to have
environmental tobacco spoke,
uh,
declared to be a,
a dangerous substance and
more heavily regulated.
And,
uh,
he thought that that was one of the
most difficult fights that he had.
His administrator,
uh,
during the,
early 1990s.
But chemicals found inside tobacco
smoke or all chemicals that,
uh,
you recognize as a hazardous substances.
Carbon monoxide,
a nicotine carcinogenic tars,
a ammonia and nitrogen dioxide,
vinyl chloride,
cyanide,
formaldehyde radionuclides,
benzene,
nitrosamines [inaudible]
aromatic hydrocarbons.
Benzo,
a Piring and arsenic.
All of these compounds are the target
of regulation under different statutes.
So it's quite remarkable that,
uh,
we've been allowed to,
to a burn cigarettes
in indoor environments.
So why the Y has a indoor environmental
quality and this problem has escaped the
attention of the environmental
protection agency.
It really has to do with the private
property rights and the perception of,
of uh,
being free from government regulation,
uh,
inside your own home or
inside your own office.
But it is quite curious.
The question about who should pay for
tobacco related illness has prompted a
much more vigorous regulatory action and
really was the basis for it for David
Kessler is initiative inside the
Food and Drug Administration,
uh,
that you read about in his book.
Question of intent.
So in 1994 on new law was passed,
authorizing the state of Florida,
the sue cigarette manufacturers
to recover their medicaid funds,
used to treat people that had
tobacco related illnesses.
So states began to recognize that their
expenditures to pay for these illnesses
were enormous.
They were in the multiple
billion dollars per year.
The law was upheld by the
Florida Supreme Court.
Uh,
and as of 1997,
41 states banded together to sue the
tobacco industry to recover these medicaid
costs.
The state settlement,
as I mentioned earlier in the lecture,
is estimated to be about $250 billion.
Uh,
additional private litigation has also
gone on in different states against
different corporations.
Uh,
states have also kind of interestingly
borrowed against their anticipated
tobacco payments.
Uh,
and,
uh,
many believed that states
have become addicted to the,
uh,
the tobacco money,
produced as a result.
So that EPA in 1990,
uh,
began attacking a passive smoking as
being causally associated with lung cancer
in adults.
Uh,
and it listed,
uh,
environmental tobacco smoke as a
group A or a known human carcinogen.
Uh,
you may think this is kind of a
modest difference in classification,
uh,
but there are relatively few known human
carcinogens that are recognized by the
National Cancer Institute.
The Centers for Disease Control,
the NRA International Agency
for research on cancer,
uh,
and the World Health Organization.
Uh,
so that,
uh,
the listing of the product
is a known human carcinogen,
gave the government and increased,
uh,
a step that they could,
use to increase debt and powerful lever,
that lever that they could use,
uh,
to,
step up,
uh,
their encouragement to
prohibit tobacco products,
uh,
from being used in public buildings.
EPA estimated in 1992 that as many as
3000 nonsmokers die from lung cancer every
year,
there are different roles
that the EPA has played.
And,
uh,
if EPA has been responsible
for environmental tobacco
smoke or secondhand smoke,
the FDA has been thought of
as the target for regulation.
Uh,
and,
uh,
that story is told,
I think very,
very well by David Kessler.
So that,
uh,
FDA's question really surrounded,
two,
two issues.
One,
whether or not,
uh,
nicotine is considered to be a drug.
A,
because under the Food
Drug and Cosmetic Act,
uh,
FDA,
eventually claimed jurisdiction,
uh,
based upon,
it's,
it's finding the f that
nicotine was a drug,
uh,
and if so,
than it needed to receive a license,
uh,
from the food and Drug Administration.
And the second question is,
uh,
under the statute is a cigarette itself,
or a cigar,
a drug delivery device for the drug.
And if he asks,
it should be regulated in possibly
prohibited under the statute.
So this question about,
uh,
addiction is quite interesting.
So if you look at,
uh,
a sales way to nicotine and tar levels
and smoke a pack as early as 1982,
uh,
you found that,
um,
uh,
has a,
a percentage of the 1992 level,
uh,
between 82 and in 1991,
that,
uh,
you find that the nicotine
levels in cigarettes increased.
Uh,
the tar levels went down,
uh,
predominantly as a product of filtration,
but something was going on.
Uh,
and what was driving this
increase in nicotine?
In fact,
a curiously,
the amount of nicotine,
uh,
in light brands,
that emerged during the 80s,
1990s,
uh,
were found to be higher than
in the regular brands just
didn't seem to make much
sense.
They also realize that if you pluck the
tobacco leaves higher up on the stock,
that they had a higher nicotine content,
uh,
in some species of plants.
So that,
uh,
that meant that the,
the tobacco growers,
uh,
the tobacco processors had the capacity
to manipulate the nicotine level based
upon the location on a stock
that the leak was pluck from.
So the question again that faced,
uh,
the food and Drug Administration,
was,
isn't it nicotine a drug a,
and here's a comment
from a Sir Charles Ellis,
uh,
from the British American Tobacco
Company Research Conference in,
uh,
1962.
It's my conviction that nicotine is
a very remarkable beneficence drug,
uh,
that both helps the body to resist
external stress and also can,
as a result show a pronounced
tranquilizing effect.
Yeah.
Nicotine is not only a very fine drug.
Uh,
he continued,
but the techniques of administration by
smoking has considerable psychological
advantage and the builtin control
against excessive absorption.
We are then in the business of
selling nicotine and addictive drug.
Uh,
by the way,
these were,
these were comments made at a private
and confidential con conference,
uh,
that,
were eventually disclosed by the
Food and Drug Administration,
uh,
in his discovery process.
And,
uh,
you can read more about that.
And the role that,
uh,
um,
deep cough played,
uh,
in,
giving,
uh,
the food and Drug Administration in
particularly Kessler Guidance and,
and,
uh,
how to get access to some
of this information that was
not in the public domain.
Uh,
he continued.
We are,
or the conviction that the ultimate
explanation for the perpetuated cigarette
habit habit resides in the pharmacological
effect of smoke upon the body and the
smoker.
I think of a cigarette pack as
a storage container for a day.
Supply of nicotine.
I think of a cigarette as a dispenser
for a dose unit of Nicotine.
I think of a puff of smoke,
uh,
as the vehicle for nicotine
smoke is beyond question,
the most optimized vehicle of nicotine.
So going back to these original
transcripts of meetings
held within the tobacco
industry,
I'll Kessler felt that he had discovered
yesterday believe that this was a,
a drug.
They believe that it was addictive.
Uh,
and they were thinking
themselves that the,
the,
the cigarette and,
uh,
cigar wrappers,
were drug delivery devices.
In a sense,
the tobacco industry may be
thought of as a specialized,
highly ritualized and stylized segment
of the pharmaceutical industry.
Again,
this is Charlie.
Claude Teague.
Tobacco products uniquely contain
and deliver nicotine a potent drug,
a with a variety of physiological effects.
They also discovered that the companies
were engaged in a plant breeding,
crying to genetically engineer
strains of tobacco plants,
uh,
that would produce higher
levels of nicotine,
uh,
particularly a strain known
as the y one nicotine,
uh,
stream.
So the percentage nicotine,
uh,
in,
why one was about threefold.
The content of a normal
flue cured tobacco,
uh,
and the ammonia,
they found was capable of liberating
free nicotine from the blend in which it
was associated,
and it increased the
impact of satisfaction.
So adding ammonia,
uh,
as,
a chemical,
uh,
component of the tobacco product a
would increase the delivery of nicotine.
So I'm going to stop there.
We're just about at time
and we'll come back to,
uh,
the more recent revisions to law are
particularly the statute that was adopted,
uh,
last June and signed by President Obama
and compare that statute to the food and
Drug Administration's proposed
regulations when Kessler was then the FDA
commissioner.
Thank you.